Baltimore is considering a curfew for
teenagers that's right in a preliminary
vote the City Council approved a bill
that could make Baltimore's curfew laws
among the strictest in the country
basically this started because of a
bunch of teens rampaging through a
7-eleven last year a lot of vandalizing
and stuff like that we've got some
details on the curfew kids under the age
of 14 would need to be home by 9:00 p.m.
year-round kids aged 14 to 16 would have
a curfew of 10:00 p.m. on weeknights
during the school year and 11:00 p.m. on
weekends there would also be a daytime
curfew during school hours and more than
one citation could result in a hefty
fine I don't like this I don't like this
I don't think we need the nanny state
that leads them to the police state
which then leads to the militarized
state I've watched a lot of science
fiction movies we've seen this movie
before yeah just take it away well III
agree with you I think this is way
overkill because it's taking and
something that did happen a real
incident did frighten people you know
there was a gang of teenagers running
around and you know I don't know exactly
how much you know havoc they read right
as teenagers do and we do see these
videos popping up in say it's always in
7-eleven right for some reason teenagers
has had to go in there and they snap up
all the slim-jim
but you know a curfew isn't necessarily
gonna make any difference on that you
have to have a police officer or other
official there to actually catch them in
the act of not meeting their curfew and
then give them a ticket at the time so
all you have to do is just not let the
cops catch you and then boom curfew is
useless it also seems to me to be overly
restrictive you know you've got kids who
have to work after school you have kids
who have to you know we have late-night
rehearsals and theater for example you
know you have to I just think it's too
restrictive and it basically punishes
all kids for just a few kids who are
unable to find something to do with
themselves right 9:00 p.m. should kids
be in bed and I mean basically you have
to be home playing video games like you
can't even be out in a park right
chasing a ball perhaps yeah what are you
doing at 9:00 p.m.
oh god last night for today yeah and
like the theater kids are the
who are definitely going out you know it
sweeps in a lot of kids that wouldn't
necessarily be the ones that are the
ones that are supposed to be targeted by
this yeah my biggest issue totally agree
is that this is conditioning these kids
that's very young age to know that if
they or their peers step out of line
then the government comes in and says
you guys cannot be trusted
with freedom you have to be contained
and restrained in your homes and I think
that that really sends a bad message to
somebody who just sort of grows up and
gets that idea at a young age that
they're going to be taken control yeah I
totally agree and that's why the part
about the school day that the curfew
would be you know warranted during the
school day is even worse to me than the
nighttime thing because playing hooky is
like part of growing up
you don't even there's a great episode
where the Simpsons where Bart doesn't go
to school in the whole episode is
Principal Skinner chasing him around
town like that's a part of growing up
and fighting the system and not being
conditioned to always believe in power
so does that part seem worse maybe than
the nighttime part the day of school you
know one of the other parts about it is
that you know they're going to find the
parents and I think that if you are a
parent and you are say working two jobs
and you're not able to be home in the
evenings and so you know obviously
sometimes teenagers are gonna go do
impulsive things like run around when
they don't have somebody so it seems
better to not punish the parents who may
not have the resources to ensure that
their teenagers are occupied and
something constructive you know maybe
the city could turn that money instead
over to programs and places for kids to
go you know so you're punishing the
people who already are behind it yeah
you know we would I would generally
guess that you know parents who have to
be at work at night are would not
appreciate you know having to be fined
for something because they don't have
the resources to give their kids
something to do so there are policies
that show that if you provide you know
basketball courts you know recreation
centers you know places for kids to go
teens to go that are safe they'll go
there yeah I remember growing up and my
dad would always be trying to get me out
of the basement playing video games with
my friends and I always were thinking if
there was a little ball court at night
we would have been running around but
there were no lip basketball courts kids
want to be outside I think generally
yeah and I say this as a as a big video
game I don't know what pretty Thomas
Edison world you grew a basketball
courts and I guess that maybe that I
grew up on the wrong side of track but
on the other side they had the live
basketball I think if the crazy thing is
especially summer is coming up July 4th
and what are they gonna have to leave
before the fireworks start at 9:00 p.m.
I mean it just seems absurdly
overreaching but I guess they could
probably be out with their parents I'm
sure there's party yeah but I mean I'm
not gonna when I was writing I wasn't
going out to with my parents to go watch
fireworks I think the real problem
obviously is the kids are acting out
this is just this is not addressing the
real issue here right what we should do
is empower adults with the ability to
just beat the [ __ ] out of these kids get
out of line and then because if there's
consequence that's related to the act of
acting out you know and if the police
aren't there you know just be like well
I had to I had to give them a weapon
because he was traipsing through the
7-eleven yeah I didn't get that we're
gonna go into the true to the pro
beating kids realm with controversy
YouTube commenters so playing the
devil's advocate a little bit so I'll
give you the child beating thing is it
maybe Oh some of this may be okay at the
most local level that if there is a town
that something was really I personally
don't agree yeah just really at the
really micro level if there was a little
town somewhere where just all hell was
breaking loose that the local
authorities yeah that's probably an
extreme case like you say you know I
could maybe see that happening and
apocalypse you guess I'm gonna need a
curfew
yeah you know but no I don't really I
don't really see why they want well I
mean actually I take that back
I do see why they would prefer to put in
a curfew because it actually requires
very little from the city as far as
resource it just means that the cops get
to go find kids to ticket and then it's
a little bit more source of revenue for
the city because they get to find
parents but you know I can see them not
wanting to put the effort into actually
dealing with the problem and creating a
solution to the problem rather than
you know putting a bandaid on it Wow a
solution to a problem rather than
conditioning kids to think that they're
criminals